the special duties unit
nicknamed flying tigers is hong kong's
main elite paramilitary special
operations unit
the sdu is a subdivision of the police
tactical unit
of the hong kong police force its
primary functions
include counter-terrorism hostage rescue
and dealing with crimes which are
considered too dangerous for the regular
police force to handle
due to the increasing threat of
international terrorism the british hong
kong government established the sdu
in 1974 at that time the unit only
consisted of around 10 members
using existing police equipment
in 1978 the british sas sent in a team
to evaluate the sdu
which in turn led to considerable change
to their operations
including the training of two land
assault teams and upgrades to their
existing equipment
then again in 1982 another team was sent
over from the british special boat
service
to set up a water assault team this unit
was disbanded in 2000
with their role being integrated into
the sdu
as their training evolved over time all
operatives were required to be trained
in both land
and water assaults after the transfer of
sovereignty over hong kong
in 1997 control of the territory was
returned to china
the sdu continued to develop training
standards and exchanges with other
top-tier
special force units from around the
world but has since developed a training
regime and methods
that are very much their own those
interested in joining the sdu
have to complete an 11 day selection
course known as hell week
this course is held annually and has a
success rate of only 25
from here applicants are required to
complete a nine-month training course
that includes weapons handling and
marksmanship tactical movement
unarmed combat breaching climbing and
roping
combat medicine and chemical biological
radiological
and nuclear incidents between 1974 and
2014
only 383 applicants were successful and
have served in the sdu
the identity of the officers in the unit
is classified with only the closest of
family members being aware of their
identity
the sdu has consistently been listed
among the most proficient special forces
units
in the world
after the reactivation of team rainbow
in 2015
two sdu operators were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale
these operators were named ying and
[Music]
[Music]
legion
so
cu mei lin code named ying is an
attacking operator in team rainbow
ying comes from a wealthy upper class
family and grew up in the central
district of hong kong
life for her was relatively easy growing
up although somewhat boring
money was never an issue and she was
provided with the best education
and had access to a multitude of tutors
which meant she could pursue her
interests with ease
her mother an enthusiastic government
worker at times was often consumed by
the world of politics
and so for a young girl growing up in a
world predominantly surrounded by adults
life was rather dull so unsurprisingly
when the conversations between the
adults started to get serious and
repeatedly monotonous
she would take the opportunity to slip
away unnoticed
exploring the city was her only
liberation from the mundane and
comfortable existence
she led she had the freedom to discover
the heart of hong kong
its people and everything it had to
offer
the mass transit railway became the most
valuable resource
which he used to traverse the city often
choosing at the last second when
and where to jump off and it was in this
way she discovered the best way to get
to know a city
is to take a shot and find the time to
let it surprise you
over the years ying started becoming
incredibly adept at strategic planning
along with being an accomplished fighter
adventures throughout the city via
trains had refined her skills
and calculating multiple adaptive routes
in fractions of a second
her ambitions to protect others was
strong and becoming a bodyguard seemed
to appeal to her nature
so after finishing high school she
promptly joined an elite security
service
when an opportunity was presented to yin
to travel to tel aviv
in israel and train with the caracal
battalion
she took it young had a first taste of
field work
at a predominantly female training
facility in tel aviv where she spent two
years training and serving
there she developed an expertise in
firearms and combat driving
eventually she returned to hong kong
where she joined the police force
and then the elite sdu flying tigers
jung has a limitless sense of adventure
and fearless enthusiasm for new
experiences
she unapologetically gets excited at the
idea of joint operations
and is often one of the first to
volunteer
heavily invested in her career and role
in law enforcement
she is often having to be forced to take
time off
[Applause]
ying's experience and exceptional skill
hit her recognized by rainbow
and she volunteered to take part in
operation high sun
jung and the team successfully delivered
the vip vehicle to its location
before returning to hq however there is
more to this mission than just that
and although a lot is heavily redacted
we know how these individuals operate
and we can read between the lines also
involved with this operation
were operators ash from the fbi and fuse
from the spit snazz
it's fairly safe to say that their
methods are quite different from yin
who tends to operate in a zero casualty
unit
ying's experience in close protection
detail has allowed her to ensure minimal
casualties
while leading high-risk vip and witness
protection operations
amidst hong kong's dense urban
population
where his views has always been about
getting the objective done
and breaking down the enemy's defenses
as quickly and efficiently as possible
to him he believes his way is the best
way and that he is the best person to
lead these ops
very much a follow me kind of guy keep
your head down
and get in and out as fast as possible
however
he insists he is not careless with other
people's lives he's just efficient at
what he does
which is most likely why there was such
a severe breakdown in communication
between him and specialist yin in
regards to the risk of multiple civilian
casualties
and ultimately what led to their big
altercation wei ying
believed him to be a questionable asset
she is the sort of person who's always
calculating the risks and wants to
understand how to wreak havoc on the
opposing team and unsettle them
but is not going to do that at the
expense of human lives
ash is the sort of individual who
appreciates high-risk high-reward
scenarios
but doesn't tend to voice what level of
potential risk to herself or others
she thinks is acceptable which means at
the time she may have aligned more with
the fuse
and has get in and get out approach
rather than yen and her methods and
concerns
in regards to the civilian lives however
ash is also the sort of person who
suffers from the lingering stress of
past combat
and often she'll dwell on things later
and analyzes every misstep
every bad call and ultimately holds
herself personally responsible for the
consequences
even in situations where she is not the
one calling the shots
even though she understands that there
is never really a situation you can be
100 prepared for
it doesn't stop her from crutinizing and
self-evaluating
so although a lot of this has been
heavily redacted in regards to operation
high sun
it's clear that there was a reasonable
amount of tension between yin and fuze
and that the quick actions of ash and
her stepping in when she did
helped quickly resolve the situation
in 2005 she collaborated with japan's
special assault team
during a security operation named
blackjack it was here that she met
specialist ekko
their objective was to ensure the
protection of japan's representative
during the world trade organizations
ministerial conference held in hong kong
it was around this time that the two
became romantically involved with one
another
however they broke up one year later
while it's sad that their relationship
didn't progress further
it should come as no surprise being as
easygoing
blends well with others takes enjoyment
and working in a team
and has an effective way of making
people feel comfortable and secure
while on the other hand echo has few
outside interests other than robotics
and consequently only thinks about
improving his own operational efficiency
those who are aware of their past
relationship often believe that when she
says
i knew a guy once it didn't mean well i
broke his drone
that she is discussing eco although it's
not entirely clear
whether she broke it while they were
together or as a consequence
of her breaking her heart
her creative use of flashbangs was
recognized during the joint training
with the sas
and it was there she earned the code
name firefly
ying's gadget is a mercury and
magnesium-based explosive
that creates a cluster of blinding
flashes
the device can either be fixed in place
or thrown like a grenade
completely non-lethal it was
specifically designed to be used in
highly populated areas like hong kong
limiting the risk of casualties
lutzelong codenamed legion is a
defending operator in team rainbow
born and raised in san guano a small
fishing and horticultural village that
lies at the northern tip
of junk bay he grew up in an
impoverished household
because of this he too had to work and
so from a very young age
spent a number of years working
alongside his father in the shipyards
there they would work together stripping
the old discarded containers
that were no longer of use of their raw
materials and parts
the work was hard dirty and dangerous
as there was often a lot of hazardous
materials about
but the long lunch breaks when he and
his father would often go fishing
and the spectacular sunrises where the
light danced across the water
where invaluable quality time to lesion
that he always cherished
unfortunately the long-term
repercussions of working around such
dangerous substances
was evident and he witnessed a lot of
the devastating lasting effects
on his fellow he grew up to have immense
respect for hazardous materials
and a deep understanding for their
effects on the human body
[Music]
in a way to provide extra income for his
family he decided to volunteer in the
yunnan and gangshi provinces
helping to clear minds it was there that
he gained the attention of the hong kong
police department
as they saw his bravery and his ability
with disarming the dangerous weapons
from there he took the opportunity
afforded to him and joined with the
explosive ordnance disposal bureau
or eod the specialized unit within the
police department
is responsible for dealing with all
illegal explosive objects
including chemical biological
radiological
and nuclear weapons in hong kong the
bureau is trained
and equipped to deal with items both on
dry land and underwater
and is called out on average over one to
two times per week
the items they deal with range from
illegal fireworks and homemade bombs
to large world war ii aircraft bombs
working with the aod gave legion the
opportunity for on-site training
so he could continue to further
specialise in chemistry and
forensic-based education
lesions knowledge with nuclear radiation
along with his expertise
in biological and chemical substances
enabled him to later join hong kong's
special duties unit
and it was there that he teamed up with
ses operators smoke
and thatcher on his first ever joint
operation
in 2017 he was officially recruited into
rainbow
his past expertise in hong kong's cbrn
made him the obvious choice during the
formation of rainbow's own cbrn threat
unit
in 2018. over the years he continues to
consult with a number of other rainbow
tech experts
and he along with fellow operators
finker and lion
often try to implement state of the art
solutions into the cbrn unit
specialist legion's teammates have a
great deal of respect for him
despite the fact that he can often drop
off the radar due to his low-key style
while on an operation lesion is intense
and focused
and thinks quickly on his feet in his
downtime
he is soft-spoken with a dry sense of
humor
legion prefers to lead a very
minimalistic life and prefers to spend
time on things that give him
satisfaction
and purpose even to this day he
continues to live close by
to where he grew up and volunteers in
cleaning up minds in his spare time
his ongoing efforts in working with the
underprivileged areas of junk bay
has been vital in successfully removing
tens of thousands of unexploded devices
legion doesn't believe in rallying up
against things that are beyond his
control
and isn't the one to count the scars
both physical and mental
he believes wholeheartedly that the good
and even the bad experiences people face
can help change sound for the better and
that the future can always be shaped
into something beautiful
legion's gadget is a hidden toxic mind
that was inspired by the sharp punjay
sticks
used in the vietnam war these sticks
were used to slow down enemy troops
by causing severe infections due to the
harsh toxins that were applied
so like these sticks legion's mine
injects a toxin that injures
and slows down opponents
we may have gotten a little carried away
with these last couple of stories they
seem to be getting longer and longer i
can only imagine how long some of the
earlier videos
like the fbi sas or spit snails would be
if we were writing them the same way
that we've done these last few
oh well thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed it and i'll catch
in the next one
cheers
you